[Música]
Estados Unidos pone fin a la
discriminación positiva en las
universidades la Corte Suprema determinó
que la raza y el origen étnico de una
persona no puede ser un criterio para
permitir su ingreso a las instituciones
educativas y finalizan así décadas de
políticas de acción afirmativa que
favorecían a minorías
la medida para inhabilitar al
expresidente de Brasil Jair bolsonaro
por abuso de poder político ya cuenta
con tres votos a favor y uno en contra
en el tribunal superior electoral y Solo
queda pendiente El veredicto de otros
tres magistrados la sesión se reanudará
este viernes
radio Caracas radio una de las emisoras
más longevas de Venezuela cierra sus
puertas tras 93 años al aire rcr Era uno
de los medios críticos del gobierno de
Nicolás maduro y había sido Sacada del
aire en 2019 pero seguía transmitiendo
por YouTube Tenemos reporte desde
Caracas
Hola Bienvenidos a este informativo de
Franz 24 en español dedicado a las
principales noticias del continente
americano soy Santiago aristee
comenzamos en Estados Unidos la Corte
Suprema de Justicia falló en contra de
la denominada acción afirmativa que
utilizaban Harvard y también la
universidad de Carolina del Norte para
otorgarle cupos específicos
afroamericanos y a latinos la denuncia
que llegó al máximo tribunal alegaba que
esto era discriminatorio contra los
bancos y los asiáticos 6 de los nueve
magistrados estuvieron a favor aquí les
contamos más detalles de la sentencia
los orígenes raciales y étnicos ya no
serán un motivo para admitir estudiantes
en Estados Unidos El argumento las
políticas de admisión conscientes de la
raza son equivalentes a discriminación
racial Harvard y la universidad de
Carolina del Norte ya habían recibido
demandas sin éxito por este tema y
recientemente el activista conservador
Edward Bloom llevó el caso a la Corte
Suprema
no se puede curar la discriminación
racial que ocurrió en el pasado con la
nueva discriminación de hoy
las políticas de admisión en cuestión
tenían en cuenta la raza entre otros
factores al elegir entre candidatos
cualificados e históricamente las
políticas han promovido la diversidad la
diversidad de Michigan tuvo que detener
su política de admisión diversa en 2006
y en los 15 años siguientes la matrícula
de afroamericanos cayó del 7 al 4%. pero
los jueces conservadores de la corte
decidieron que la raza no podía ser un
factor en las admisiones universitarias
el presidente biden citó a las voces
disidentes en la Corte Suprema la
disidencia establece la decisión de hoy
cita hace retroceder décadas de Progreso
trascendental y precedente fin de la
cita estoy de acuerdo con esa
declaración de los disidentes
agregando que la discriminación Todavía
existe en Estados Unidos Mientras tanto
la derecha estadounidense saludó el
fallo como una victoria para la
meritocracia el expresidente Donald
Trump calificó el jueves como un gran
día para Estados Unidos y su principal
rival para las primarias republicanas
dijo que la decisión acaba con la
discriminación por parte de los colegios
y universidades
seis de los nueve jueces de la Corte
Suprema Fueron designados por
presidentes republicanos y la línea
conservadora fue noticia el año pasado
por anular el derecho constitucional al
aborto
seguimos en Estados Unidos un Jurado de
Florida absolvió este jueves a un ex
agente acusado de no proteger a los
estudiantes durante el tiroteo masivo de
2018 en una escuela secundaria en la
ciudad de parkland el ex oficial estaba
acusado de negligencia infantil
negligencia culposa y perjurio por
presuntamente no haber actuado durante
la masacre que dejó a 17 personas
muertas
y la ola de calor que afecta al sur de
Estados Unidos se extiende por tercera
semana consecutiva y el servicio
nacional del clima reporta alertas rojas
por las posibilidades de incendios y
avisos de altas temperaturas en Estados
como Luisiana Alabama y Arkansas
mientras que en Houston Texas sigue
vigente el plan de emergencia que se
activó desde el 14 de junio y las
autoridades locales recomendaron ser
precavidos a pesar de que se espera que
llueva
la ciudad de Houston ha tomado varias
medidas para mantener a todos fresco
la ciudad activó su plan de emergencia
de calor de salud pública el 14 de junio
cuando el área de Houston comenzó a
experimentar Un calor excesivo
y estamos brindando recursos para que
las personas se refugien del calor
francamente tenía la esperanza de que a
estas alturas las cosas se hubieran
calmado un poco pero ese no ha sido el
caso
y esta misma ola de calor ha afectado a
México así más de 100 personas murieron
por las altas temperaturas de las
últimas tres semanas según un reporte
del sistema de vigilancia epidemiológica
en algunas regiones los termómetros
marcaron más de 40 grados el informe es
de Max Pérez Gallardo
112 mexicanos fallecidos por la ola de
calor la secretaría de salud del país
Azteca informó que entre el primero y el
22 de junio las altas temperaturas
reportadas en la mayor parte del
territorio se curaron la vida de más de
un centenar de personas Nuevo León
Sonora Tamaulipas Tabasco y Veracruz son
los principales estados afectados donde
hay localidades que sobrepasan los 40
grados en sus termómetros pues si no se
está afectando bastante digo ahorita
el cambio climático pues está estamos
viendo las consecuencias no Y obviamente
de nosotros pero es parte de no tenemos
que trabajar tenemos que llevar el
sustento a la casa las altas
temperaturas no solo afectan a las
grandes urbes mexicanas en Chiapas
cientos de indígenas tóxiles sufren por
escasez de agua La ola de calor ha
secado el pozo de la comunidad de
Guadalupe schukum dejando sin agua
decenas de familias
no hay nada allá en el pozo nada de agua
por eso día de noche estamos esperando o
no ha llovido
no ha llovido nada
ahorita como estamos sufriendo de cero
ahorita no hay agua a pesar de que el
servicio meteorológico nacional anunció
que la entrada de dos fenómenos
meteorológicos provocarán lluvias
torrenciales en el sureste del país un
grupo de científicos de la Universidad
Autónoma de México asevera que una
cuarta ola de calor podría azotar el
país a partir del primero de julio y
cientos de policías allanaron cárceles
de alta seguridad en Honduras en su
intento por arrebatar el control de las
prisiones a las pandillas los operativos
se llevaron a cabo en dos centros
penitenciarios después de que 46
reclusas murieran en enfrentamientos
entre bandas rivales Durante los
operativos se incautaron armas que según
la policía son introducidas de
contrabando por pandilleros en las
prisiones con la ayuda de guardias
corruptos
vamos ahora a Brasil porque cuatro de
los siete magistrados del tribunal
supremo electoral se emitieron sus votos
en medio del juicio contra el
expresidente Jair bolsonaro tres de
ellos apoyaron inhabilitarlo y sólo uno
se mostró a favor del ex mandatario por
lo que la medida necesitaría solo un
voto más para obtener la mayoría
bolsonaro es acusado de abuso de poder
político durante las elecciones de 2022
cuando convocó a Embajadores extranjeros
para desacreditar el sistema electoral
justo antes de la votación la sesión fue
suspendida y se reanudará este viernes
el líder conservador se defendió
si estoy fuera del juego político seré
un ciudadano Tal vez un buen activista
hay varios buenos nombres por ahí
pero creo hasta el último segundo en la
imparcialidad y en un juicio justo y sin
revanchismo del tse
soy
y en otras noticias radio Caracas radio
una de las emisoras más longevas de
Venezuela cierra sus puertas de manera
definitiva tras 93 años de existencia
rsr había sido Sacada del aire en 2019
pero continuaba transmitiendo a través
de YouTube ampliamos desde Caracas con
nuestra corresponsal Daniela Zambrano
este viernes 30 de junio la emisora más
longeada de Venezuela radio Caracas
radio cesará definitivamente sus
operaciones luego de haberse mantenido
los últimos cuatro años de forma digital
recordemos que esta emisora La más
longeva del país fue Sacada del aire en
2019 por orden de la Comisión Nacional
de telecomunicaciones tras haber
transmitido el alzamiento dirigido por
Juan guaidó y Leopoldo López junto a un
grupo de militares contra la
administración de Nicolás maduro era una
de las pocas emisoras que mantenía una
postura crítica al gobierno y en el que
partidos políticos y dirigentes
opositores tenían espacios en el último
año la Comisión Nacional de
telecomunicaciones ha ordenado el cierre
de cerca de ciento siete emisoras en
todo el país dirigentes políticos
organizaciones no gubernamentales y por
supuesto el gremio periodístico ha
lamentado esta decisión luego de que la
emisora no pudiese subsistir sólo a
través de redes sociales
y la compañía Virgin galactic realizó su
primer vuelo suborbital comercial con
tres italianos a bordo el avión espacial
vss Unity se elevó a más de 80
kilómetros sobre el desierto de Nuevo
México y una vez dejó la nave nodriza
sobrevoló por 75 minutos los dos
oficiales de la fuerza aérea italiana y
el ingeniero aeroespacial que pagaron
por la experiencia estuvieron junto a
tres tripulantes de la compañía que
pilotearon la nave Desde allí miraron
por un corto tiempo parte del planeta
Tierra
esto por el momento sigan en France 24 y
en France 24.com
[Música]